just as her delusions about her own
self-image ran wild in 1918 she sees
these relations happen and believes that
she can have the same effect that
evening she dresses up and tries to
seduce Howard which he has to turn down
because of his bad heart once again
Pearl can't get what she wants while
those younger and prettier get
everything that she's ever wanted it's
the dance try out all over again later
that night she wakes up unable to
contain her geriatric horniness and ends
up scaring the crap out of the
heartbroken camera guy on his way out of
the farm he gets out of the van to check
on her as if she were a loose patient
wandering the halls of a nursing home
also everyone's favorite song which is
totally not overused in movies and TV is
playing on the
radio little does he know Pearl is the
same desperate attention starved woman
that she's always been and when he goes
to help she tries to kiss him look at me
like you looked at her what